[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je sais déjà
c'est ma soeur c'est ma soeur valérie
hains d'accord boussens valérie voyez
vous c'est votre prénom alors je suis
bernard tard un champion du monde de
nazo flûte donc ma soeur ma soeur est
championne du monde de saxophones mais
ce soit en affaires je vous présente mon
guitariste paco rabanne dit j'aime bien
lui l'arrière salle j'aime bien dit lui
j'aime bien un petit je pense que vous
avez un petit hic avec ma soeur m'a
écouté il va pas être compostés
[Applaudissements]
t'inquiète pas je te retrouverai vous
pouvez calme et bon quand même
alors on va donc interpréter des
génériques télé ouais avec le nez c'est
absolument nasaux fumants qui a cloné
générique extraite de la télévision il
faut retrouver bien sûr l'émission
d'accord vous travaillez sur des grands
prix de formule 1 du tout dans ses
tenues officielles sens très bien
attention essayer de jouer également
chez vous on y va et vous votre soeur
commence à me plaire tant mieux tant
mieux allez on a les oreilles des livres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien
je n'ai pas ça tombe bien ça parce que
toi je vais dire mettre des trucs
conseils pas trop communiquer avec cette
personne va pas du tout alors bosse ici
c'est quoi
[Musique]
on oublie on passe au deuxième kembo la
baraque à frites
ah oui georges pas touche pas droite
était dégueulasse pas laisser faire ça
il est fou lui
[Musique]
aho
le label
c'est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième était très longue bien quand
même
huawei confesse plus court du coup bah
oui parce que si vous faites tous les
génériques à chaque fois dans la
légalité on va pas s'en sortir alors
j'aime bien ça j'aime bien tout court
ben quoi l'udc ou hockey musique alors
et vous voulez qu'ils leur fassent
mouche et les attentions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vachement bien fait mais bien
merci
merci à vous merci monsieur tard merci
bien merci madame merci beaucoup je vous
souhaite une très belle soirée l'autisme
on va écouter aller
je veux tout ça
[Applaudissements]